submergée il ya quelques semaines le
royaume uni relève désormais la tête le
8 mars prochain
les anglais commenceront leur
déconfinement après plus de deux mois de
mise sous cloche
ce lundi le premier ministre britannique
boris johnson a dévoilé la ligne de
conduite choisi par le gouvernement
l'étape 4 commencera au plus tôt le 21
juin avec des mesures d'atténuation
appropriées
nous nous efforcerons de supprimer
toutes les limites légales concernant
les contacts sociaux les mariages et
autres événements de la vie nous
n'ouvrirons tout compris les boîtes de
nuit et autoriseront les grands
événements tels que les représentations
théâtrales au delà des limites de
l'étape 3 en recourant éventuellement au
dépistage pour réduire le risque
d'infection
cette levée des restrictions
constituerait la quatrième et ultime
étape du plan de déconfinement avant
cela le gouvernement soit rouvrir les
écoles le 8 mars prochain
dans deux semaines les élèves et les
étudiants de toutes les écoles et de
tous les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur pourront reprendre
l'enseignement en présentiel en toute
sécurité grâce à des tests effectués
plus par semaine sur les élèves du
secondaire et des universités
les commerces sont essentielles sont
quant à eux concernés par la deuxième
étape du déconfinement à partir du 12
avril
en 3e étape le retour des spectateurs
lors des événements sportifs est espérée
à partir du 17 mai à travers ces quatre
étapes
boris johnson semble ne pas vouloir se
précipiter il est tellement crucial que
cette feuille de route soit prudente
mais aussi irréversible nous nous
engageons sur ce qui je l'espère et je
le crois devrait être un chemin sens
unique vers la liberté et ce voyage est
rendue possible par le rythme du
programme de vaccination
si les dates annoncées ne sont pas
figées elles sont également porteuses
d'espoir outre-manche alors que le
royaume-uni est le pays européen le plus
meurtri par la pandémie